قال نائب رئيس مجلس السياده في السودان
مالك عقار الذي اشار الى وجود ما سماها
تقارير غير مؤكده عن اتصالات بين مجموعه
فاجنر الروسيه ووحدات من قوه الدعم السريع
قال للجزيره ان باجنر قد تكون لها علاقات
استثماريه مع الدعم السريع وكان عقار قد
دعا روسيا للعب دور في انهاء ازمه السودان
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات في اي سياق تاتي زياره
عقار الى موسكو وحديثه عن دوري فاغنر في
السودان ودعوته لدور الروسي في تسويه
النزاع ومن رسائل التي يبعثها توقيت زياره
وكيف
ستتعاطى روسيا مع هذه الدعوه وما الذي
يعنيه توسطها في الازمه السودانيه الان
بالنظر للتغيرات الداخليه فيها والمبادرات
الاقليميه والدوليه لحل نزاع السودان
وما هي حسابات اللاعبين الاقليميين
والدوليين في السودان التي تؤخر توفير ضغط
كاف على طرفي الازمه من اجل وقف اطلاق
النار واطلاق حوار لحلها
[موسيقى]
بعد تصريحات ادلى بها في موسكو دعى فيها
روسيا للعب دور في حل الازمه الراهنه في
السودان
وكشف خلالها ما سماها تقارير غير مؤكده عن
صلات بين مجموعه باجنر وقوه الدعم السريع
وحذر من وجود فاجنر في بعض دول الجوار
السوداني رغم نفيه وجودها فيها رجح نائب
رئيس مجلس السياده في السودان ملك عقار ان
يكون ليفاجنر علاقه مع قوه الدعم السريع
على مستوى الاستثمارات
ليست موجوده في السودان لكنها موجوده في
عدد من الدول المجاوره وفي المناطق
الحدوديه هي شركه عسكريه خاصه لديها شبه
كبير مع قوات الدعم السريع التي هي ايضا
قوه عسكريه خاصه في السودان وهي المتسببه
في المشكله الحاليه اعتقد ان لديها ايضا
العديد من الاتفاقات مع دول مجاوره لنا في
السودان قد تكون لها علاقه بقوات الدعم
السريع لكن على مستوى الاستثمارات
موقع المنشره الاخباري الذي هكذا يراقب عن
كثب نشاط مجموعه باجنر في الشرق الاوسط في
خضم تساؤلات بشان مستقبل هذه المجموعه نقل
او نقل عن مسؤول عسكري امريكي قوله ان
فاجنر تحتفظ بوجود ضئيل في السودان بعد
اندلاع العنف الاخير
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من ام
درمان الكاتبه المحلل السياسي احمد عمر
خووجلي ومن فيرجينيا كاميرون هاتسون
مستشار المبعوث الامريكي السابق الى
السودان ومسؤول شؤون افريقيا السابق في
البيت الابيض
وينضم الينا عبر الهاتف من موسكو الباحث
المتخصص في العلاقات الدوليه
اهلا بكم جميعا الى هذه الحلقه وابدا معك
سيد احمد عمر خوجه لفاندرمان برايك ما
الذي يبحث عنه مالك عقار في موسكو
مرحب بكم اولا
عقار بزيارته لموسكو يعني بدايه يؤكد على
عدم وجود اي عزله للحكومه السودانيه
والدوله السودانيه تتحرك حركه مريحه من
خلال الزيارات والاستقبال الرسمي للرؤساء
والمسؤولين هذه واحده المساله الاخرى
المهمه ما له عقار والحكومه السودانيه ككل
يبحثون عن فضاءات جديده لخيارات ومبادرات
تختلف عن التي تم تجربها في الفتره
السابقه منذ اندلاع على الحرب في 15 ابريل
الماضي وربما كانت يعني تعارض المصالح
الدوليه
واختلاف المواقع المواقف المختلفه تاتي
بجديد عبر روسيا لاندفاع المصلحه المباشره
كما حدث كما يعني اشتكت الحكومه السودانيه
من مبادره السابقه وعدم في اذيتها وعدم
بحثها عن المصلحه الحقيقيه للمواطنين
السودانيين
ربما ذلك عقاري يريد بزيارته ان
يبحثون هل يمكن ان يجد اذا الملك عقار في
موسكو ما لم يجده في الرياض في واشنطن في
ايجاد في الاتحاد الافريقي
اعتقد ان هذا صحيح وانا مالك عقار يبحث
عنه في موسكو هو التحدث الى الروس حول منع
دعمه
لدعم السريع
وهناك تقارير ان
مجموعه فاقدر توفر
للدعم السريع بعض الدعم عبر ليبيا وعبر
افريقيا الوسطى
الحكومه سودانيه تريد ان لا تصل تلك
المساعدات ومن الواضح ان روسيا تحاول ان
تستعيد
سيطره او المجال الذي كانت تسيطر فيه
مجموعه فاغنر وان تلعب دورا وسيطا مثل ما
راينا ما تفعله واشنطن والسعوديه
ما تريده
السودان هو منع مثل هذا الدعم وان لا تكون
في مركز قوي ما نوع الدم الذي قصدته لانه
هناك حديث عن استثمارات في السودان لكن
انت تقصد اي نوع من الدعم
يعني صواريخ ارض جو
واسلحه
وربما وقود وبعض هذه الاسلحه تاتي عبر
مجموعه فاغنر من جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
او عبر ليبيا وعبر ميليشيات حفتر في ليبيا
التي كانت تدعم
قوه الدعم السريع
واذا الحكومه السودانيه تريد ان تمنع ذلك
الدعم
وهو يتكلم باسم الحكم الحكومه السودانيه
ويريد ان يقطع ذلك الدعم عن الدعم السريع
هنا نتحدث عن الدعم العسكري واعود الى
احمد عمر خوجلي اذا تحدثنا عن الدعم
السياسي وهناك حديث طبعا عن تصويت محتمل
في مجلس الامن الدولي على خطوات عمليه
لوقف القتال في السودان الى اي مدى يمكن
التعويل على موسكو في رفع الفيتو الروسي
في وجه اي عقوبه ضد السودان
هو اتجاه مهم جدا وضروري ومجرب
المبادرات السابقه كما ذكرت يعني تجاوزت
الخيارات السودانيه الاصيله التي يبحث
عنها السودانيون
وباتت يعني يعني في يعني الحكومه
السودانيه باتت يعني لا تفضلها ولم تجتهد
معها واردت شكواها المستمره من هذه
المبادلات ومن طبيعتها ومن عدم هي اديتها
اتجاه الطرفين المتحاربين الان هي تساوي
بين الدعم السريع وبين القوات المسلحه
السودانيه وهي يعني طرحت خيارات تتصل
بتفريغ العاصمه السودانيه من المسلحين
والقوات المسلحه بالضروره يعني وصفها
لانها اشبه بالاحتلال هذه المبادلات باتت
يعني من يعني من الماضي تقريبا
والمساله التي تتصل بمجلس الامن ربما
يتعلق بخطوات لا نقصد عقوبات ولكن خطوات
عمليه لوقف القتال في السودان هل يمكن
التعويل فعلا على موسكو وموقفها في مجلس
الامن الدولي هذا هو السؤال
نعم اذا حاولت الولايات المتحده او مجلس
الامن الضغط على السودان عبري عبر اليات
مجلس الامن السودان بالضروره بحوجه الى
الفيديو الروسي
تحت ظلال الخلافات الكبيره بين روسيا
والولايات المتحده الاسنان يحتاج الى ذلك
ومرجح جدا ان تكون روسيا الى جانبه من
خلال هذه العمل الذي يتعارض مع السياسات
الدوليه لكلا الطرفين الولايات المتحده
وروسيا لذلك هي تعود على ذلك وتعتمد على
ذلك وهذه الزياره واحده
هل يمكن ان تدخل فعلا على خط الوساطه في
الملف السوداني
الدفنه 30 انا اعتقد انه يمكن لموسكو ان
تتوسط في كل ما يتعلق بشؤون سودانيه
اولا هناك سوابق تاريخيه لمشاركه موسكو
الافريقيه كذلك يمكنني ان اقول بالنسبه
الى بعض الدول الافريقيه يمكن
ان تكون موسكو الحله الافضل
مقارنه بالقوى الغربيه لان القوى الغربي
اليها على انها تتدخل في الشؤون الداخليه
في عدد من الدول تتدخل حتى في قضايا
ايديولوجيه
تمارس ضغوطات ايديولوجيه بالنسبه الى
الصين الصين لها دور مهم ولكن عاده ينظر
الى الصين على انها قوه عظمى ناشئه وربما
استعماريه جديده اذا يمكنني موسكو ان تكون
الحليف الافضل او المفضل من اجل التوسط لا
سيما في الوضع في السودان وهنا تحديدا ما
المقارنه التي يمكن ان تقدمها موسكو يعني
في ماذا تختلف عن المبادرات السابقه
الاتحاد الافريقي ايجاد جده في السعوديه
اعتقد ان هذه المبادره الجديده ليست بشيء
يمكن ان نعتبره عصا سحريه ليس هناك معجزات
هنا ولكنها تبقى مقاربه عمليه افضل يمكن
ان تدعوا موسكو الطرفين الى
روسيا للتفاوض ربما لما لا قد يكون مشروعا
ما ملامحها برايك
ما ملامح هذه المقاربه والمبادره برايك
تقوم بما ثابت مفاوضات بقياده موسكو او
ربما تقام في موسكو او في السودان ولاحقا
حتى للجوانب العسكريه ايضا قد يكون لها
دور او تدرجنا المبادره روسيا تعيد تشكيل
مجموعه او مجموعات اخرى تحت اسماء جديده
هي ربما ليست ناشطه في السودان ولكن ربما
تنشط لاحقا وهذا يعني ان هناك مبادره
انفاذ قانون يمكن لروسيا ان تقودها من
خلال مجموعه فاكرير او مثيلاتها وربما
يمكنها ان تفرض النظام العام والقانون في
بعض الدول
برايك ما مدى واقعيه هذا الكلام حول دور
الذي يمكن ان تلعبه روسيا في الملف
السوداني
اعتقد ان روسيا ليس لديها تاريخ لعب ادوار
دبلوماسيه او دوار الوساطه في السودان
التفاوض يتم معه هي تتفاوض مع تحالفاتها
وهدفها الاول هو الحصول على قاعده بحريه
على البحر الاحمر
لمصالحها الاستراتيجيه واعتقد ان ذلك الى
حد انها تعرض خدماتها الان وذلك
للتقدم في ذلك الملف ونرى موسكو خلال
سنوات الاخيره في السودان
تحاول ان تتماشى مع الطرفين المتصارعين
حاليا
في المحادثات الرسميه للحصول على تلك
القاعده
ولمساعده الدعم السريع من ناحيه اخرى اذا
موسكو تحاول ان تتفاهم مع اي طرف سواء كان
الجانب العسكري للقوات المسلحه او حركه
تعمل بمقتضى مصالحها الذاتيه
وتريد انا ساكون متشائما
بصدد او بشان هذه الجهود التي تقوم بها
لتلعب دورا
دبلوماسيا
فهي لا تخدم الا مصالحها
يعني ليست جمعيه خيريه
وكما كان يقول الان يعني وهناك مصالح
روسيه في هذا الموضوع وتحدث عن قاعده
بحريه واشياء اخرى الان عندما تعول يعول
السودان او تعوي الخرطوم على دور روسي في
مجلس الامن على فيتو روسي في مجلس الامن
الدولي ماذا يمكن ان تقدم المقابل الذي
تقدمه الخرطوم لروسيا في هذه الحال
والله يجب ان لا نظلم روسيا ايضا روسيا
روسيا باطنه الان تحاول ان تعيد روسيا
القديمه التي تتصرف بعد الشعوب العالم
الثالث ولها صداقات قديمه والتسليحه
السوداني منذ حكم الرئيس الاسبق عبود كان
روسي يعني روسيا تحاول ان تعيد الدوره
القديمه الذي كانت تعمل في على يعني
نشر صداقتها مع الشعوب والدول والسلاله
تلك الصداقه
الصداقات بين الشعوب اكيد هناك مصالح
ملموسه تسعى اليها روسيا ما الذي يمكن ان
يقدمه السودان لروسيا على هذا الصعيد في
مقابل الدوري الروسي
نعم العالم كله يبحث عن مصالح والسودان
يبحث عن مصالح والاستقرار والامن وامريكا
تبحث عن مصالح الايديولوجيه والمصالح
الماليه والمصالح حلفائها في المنطقه
روسيا الان طموحات وطموحاتها تتصل
بصناعه دور متوازن وفورص متوازنه امام
السودان حتى يلعبوا الاستقرار روسيا تبحث
عن مصالحها والجمع يبحثون عن مصالحهم ولكن
المصالح الروسيه الاستغراب
بلد واعد وفيه كثير من فرص الاستثمار
المختلفه وله موانئ على البحر الاحمر وله
خيارات كثيره في الزراعه وكثير من الفرص
التي الان تبحث عنها فاقدر الذهب وكثير من
المصادر الطبيعيه تبحث عنها روسيه واذا
كان البحث عن المصائب هو المصالح هو لغه
العالم الان اذا كان المصالح مع الاستقرار
ومع الدوله السودانيه وبقائها فمرحبا
بالمصالح الروسيه متى ما كانت متوازنه
وموجوده والعالم الان عالم مصالح
وفوائد
متابع كيف تنظر الى دور اللاعبين
الاقليميين والدوليين ايضا في يعني
التوافق على الضغط على ممارسه الضغط على
طرفي الصراع لوقف القتال والذهاب نحو حوار
بناء بين الطرفين
الاطراف سوف
تصل الى مرحله تستفيد فيها من بناء الدوله
روسيا طبعا سوف تكون جزءا من هذا التحالف
الذي من شانها ان يساعد السودان وطبعا
روسي لديها مصالحها المرتبطه بالقاعده
البحريه في السودان ولكن الامر لا يقتصر
على ذلك روسيا تحاول ان تطبق استراتيجيه
الجنوب الاوسع لكي تكون جزء من الشون
الافريقيه اما الاتحاد الافريقي والمنظمات
الاقليميه الاخرى هي ايضا مرحب بها
وامريكا والصين كذلك مرحبا بهما حتى ان
امريكا والصين ستحاولان فرض مصالحهما
مصالح المصالح القوى الاقليميه والمنظمات
الاقليميه الاتحاد الافريقي الذي ربما
يتحرك بناء على ضغط من بيجين او واشنطن
اذا هي هو مزيج من القوى والتاثيرات نرى
الان مثلا ان جميع القوى الخارجيه يهمها
من اصلاحتها ان يتوقف القتال وان ينتهي
انعدام الاستقرار لان هذا اذا لم يحصل قد
يؤدي الى مزيد من موجات الهجره المقلقه
هناك ايضا خطط لها علاقه بانابيب النفط
والغاز التي قد تمر الى البحر الاحمر عبر
السودان ونحن بحاجه الى الاستقرار لهذه
الغايه من وجهه نظري كل الاطراف سوف تكون
مشاركه قبل قليل تحدثت عن موضوع انشاء
قاعده بحريه وعن مصالح روسيه في السودان
هناك قراءه ايضا تقول انه دخول موسكو على
الخط هو محاوله ايضا لابتزاز الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لانك كما قلت انت ايضا
قبل قليل ليس في التقاليد السياسيه
الروسيه القيام بدور وساطات في الملفات
المعقده هل ينظر امريكيا الى ان موسكو
تزاحم واشنطن تحاول ان تبتزها ربما في هذا
الملف
اعتقد اننا راينا من روسيا
وكلائها مجموعه
استراتيجيه حقيقيه في افريقيا لتطوير
علاقات
تاخذ مكان الغرب او على حساب الغرب في
مالي ونعرف انهم يزيدون تاثيرهم في بلدان
اخرى هناك استراتيجيه
تقوم بها موسكو خلال السنوات القليله
الاخيره في
افريقيا لدعم افريقيا في التخفيف من
التاثير الغربي
السودان هي مكان اخر
يمكنهم ان يخدموا فيه هذه المصالح
وفي ايضا جنوب افريقيا
ومناطق اخرى هذه الاستراتيجيه ومره اخرى
اعتقد انها تستخدم
على المقاطعه لكن كيف يمكن ان تتصرف
واشنطن ازاء هذا
كيف يمكن اذا ان تتصرف واشنطن ازاء هذا
كانت تحاول ان
تلعب دور الوساطه في السودان وان تمارس
ضغوطا وايضا بالضغوط حتى يتم انهاء القتال
ولم يتحقق نجاح كبير وهذه الحرب مستمره
وليس في مصلحه احد ان يرى السودان تصبح
دوله فاشله لاسباب ارهاب او هجره
تتقاسم العديد من المصالح لروسيا والصين
في المنطقه ولكن ما يثير قلق واشنطن ليس
فقط هو
التوصل الى حل ولكن كيف يمكن ان نحول
السودان الى حكومه ديمقراطيه مدنيه وهذه
المصلحه هي التي
يحصل فيها فارق بين مساعي
الولايات المتحده او الصين او موسكو هل
السيد خجلي في حسابات الخرطوم يعني هناك
العقل السياسي في الخرطوم يفكر في هذا
الموضوع الحرص على الديمقراطيه وكل ما
ذكره قبل قليل سيد هاتشون
هل تراعي ايضا القلق الامريكي في هذا
الصدد
الامريكي من المسائل المتصله
بالايدولوجيا الراسماليه والامريكيه الروح
والانسان
والديمقراطيه ونشر الفكره الديمقراطي هذه
واحده من المحركات الاساسيه لجهود
الولايات المتحده لكن الواقع السوداني
يعني يحتاج الى واقعيه اكثر يحتاج الى
نظره مختلفه وربما هذا التداخل الروسي
والترويحه السوداني بادخال روسيا في الملف
يمكن ان يجعل من الولايات المتحده ان تنظر
الى السودان بشكل مختلف ليست بؤرتين
مباشره وطلبان مباشر لكثير من العقبات
التي ذكرتها لك الان اذا الولايات المتحده
نزلت الى الامر السوداني باعتباره حاله
استثنائيه تتطلب جزم الوقت وجزم وكثير من
الحكمه حتى تستصحب الراي العام السوداني
جميعه في عمليه سياسيه ترضي الجميع
فسوف تقدم للسودان الكثير من الخدمه وتجلب
الاستقرار لكن بهذه الطريقه الاولى التي
تجعل من بعض القوه هي التي تحاول تشكل
المستقبل
نعم فقط في دقيقه واحده ما هو تصورك انت
للحل
اعتقد انه في نهايه المطاف وبمساعده القوى
الخارجيه بما فيها روسيا طبعا وربما ايضا
القوى الاقليميه على غير الاتحاد الافريقي
وربما بعض الدول الافريقيه في النهايه
سيكون هناك تنسيق للجهود من اجل ايجاد
حكومه مستقره في السودان ربما قد لا تكون
ديمقراطيه ولكن هذا موضوع ايديولوجي ما
يهم هو ان تكون الحكومه مستقره بغض النظر
عن المقاربه سواء الديمقراطيه ام لا شكرا
لك اشكرك جزيل الشكر انتهى وقت البرنامج
شكرا لك
الباحث المتخصص في العلاقات الدوليه كنت
معنا من موسكو ومن امدرمان الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي السوداني احمد عمر خوجلي شكرا لك
ونشكر ايضا ضيفنا من فيرجينيا كاميرون
هاتسون مستشار المبعوث الامريكيه السابق
للسودان ومسؤول شؤون افريقيا السابق
في البيت الابيض
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر لكم منا اطيب المنى والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]